our plan today is we're going to go
through
five good things about russ
one bad thing about russ to be
even-handed here
and then one more thing
okay
so our first good thing
is that rust is
an
empowering language
and in other words i mean
everyone
is big enough
big enough to do systems programming
traditionally systems programming has
meant that you're programming in c or c
plus
so that your code runs fast and doesn't
use a lot of memory or time
spent from the cpu
but in order to get these advantages
you have to trade off the memory safety
that higher level languages give you
with garbage collection
and you have to manage the memory
yourself
which tends to lead to memory unsafety
problems such as use after free where
you clean up memory that you're managing
manually and then you try to use it
again
double free where you clean up memory
twice and that can lead to memory
corruption
buffer overreads and overwrites where
you access beyond the end of your data
structure because you're doing pointer
arithmetic
and you
your code is accessing memory that
it shouldn't be accessing
and null pointers where you think you
are pointing to some valid data
and actually you're pointing to nothing
and you either have to check for that
case everywhere
or if you miss a check
you
might be trying to do something with
nothing
a lot of programmers
i should i should be nowhere near
production c or c plus because i do not
know everywhere
that
you might be i might be writing
memory unsafe code
and there's a lot of corner cases and
weird parts of cm placebos plus you have
to be an expert in cnc plus plus to be
writing
production level
code and
but so people seem to say
i've seen people say that
oh programmers just need to be more
careful and if they were more careful
and knew more then we wouldn't have all
these memory unsafe problems that lead
to crashes and vulnerabilities and
exploits
but
we've we've had c for 40 years and we
have seen that
being more careful
does not work humans are not capable of
being careful enough to write safe
production c and c plus plus
the proof that i have for this is that
both microsoft and the chrome team have
come out with articles where they've
analyzed all the
security bugs that they've had in
windows and in chrome
and both of them have found that 70 of
their security bugs have been due to
memory safety issues
and
the fact that both of these companies
are large and able to pay for experts in
these programming languages
and there's they're
able to get the most careful programmers
yet they still end up with 70
of these security problems
caused by memory and safety says to me
that
there
there's no way to fix this 70
by being more careful
we need to do something else
and
you might think well maybe we should
make c better
but there's this great article that i
recently saw from
john haydmanid
called why the c language will never
stop you from making mistakes
the short answer is because the c
standards committee has decided to value
backwards compatibility
over fixing problems or warning you of
mistakes or
stopping you from writing
code that might be memory unsafe
and that's a perfectly valid decision to
make for
the language that backwards committee
compatibility is
the most important thing
it's just that
i
don't see myself spending enough time to
even be a halfway competent programmer
in c
to get
fast low resource
usage code
and that is where rust comes in
rust is a systems programming language
it's been stable for five years now
and it also runs fast and
is able to use low amounts of resources
but
it doesn't have the memory on safety
problems by default
it is a memory safe language
unless you choose to opt out of it in
certain areas at certain points very
explicitly
this memory safety is guaranteed at
compile time rust won't even let you
compile let alone run
code that violates its memory safety
guarantees
and these guarantees apply across
multiple threads
so writing multi-threaded cnc plus is
even another level of
expertise that you need to have
and not many people are capable of but
in rust the compiler helps any
programmer
write systems programming code
and i'm not saying that russ prevents
all mistakes what i am saying is that we
have these old mistakes in c and c plus
plus that we know lots about we've seen
them over and over and over again
and all i'm saying is that let's stop
making the old mistakes
so that we can make some new mistakes
the other way i like to think about rust
is that
it makes memory safety the compiler's
responsibility and computers are
extremely good at keeping track of
tedious
details that
are involved in ensuring memory safety
and that leaves me free
to concentrate on my domain logic what
my program should actually be doing
what a human needs to understand about
my code
and that is really freeing and
lets me do what i'm good at unless the
computer do what it's good at
which brings us to
the second good thing about rust
ownership
this is how rust ensures that there's
memory safety at compile time
and you can think of ownership as
clean up pick up memory
clean up
what you own
ownership is a system in rest where
there is one owner of each piece of data
one variable designated as the owner
when the owner of that data goes out of
scope
the data gets cleaned up
and you don't have to write free or
explicitly say that in your code
owner of a piece of data can transfer
ownership to another variable
or it can lend out that data which is
borrowing and we'll talk about borrowing
in a minute
let's take a look at this encode
this is a main function in rest
and we are
creating a variable named x
and we are
putting an allocated string
in
and it is going to be owned by x
this string from allocates memory on the
heap and we could grow this string if we
wanted to
x is the owner
and when the owner goes out of scope at
the end of main the memory allocated for
the string gets cleaned up
the code that does the cleaning up gets
inserted at compile time by the compiler
and there is no garbage collector
running at runtime to do this cleaning
up
so let's take a look at a situation
where we
transfer ownership
in this code we have the x with the
allocated string again
and then we say let y equals x
which transfers ownership from x to y
then
in the next line we try and print out x
again and in many other programming
languages
the third line in the body of the
function would work fine and we'd be
able to print out the value of x
but in rust
this
is a compile time error because we've
moved ownership from x to y
and after that point x no longer has
access to
the memory that it used to own that's
now y owns
this is important because at the end of
the function
y is now responsible for cleaning up the
memory not x
so there will only be one and only be
exactly one
uh cleaning up
of the memory that was allocated
that gets rid of
the double freeze and use after freeze
and
and
various problems like that
this code might look a little
inconvenient though if you're used to
being able to
have
use of x after
assigning its y
which brings us to good thing number
three that rust has
borrowing
you can borrow a memory and then i'll
get it back
borrowing is a way that an owner can let
some other part of code
read or write to
that data without transferring ownership
and you do that with an ampersand this
might look like a reference
and
this might look like a pointer
that you might be familiar with with
other languages and rest this is called
a reference
and another way to say it is that this
is an immutable borrow
that y has of the data that is still
owned by x
with why having a borrow of the data in
x then we are able to run
this code that
accesses both
the memory at x through through x and
through y
accessing the same heat memory
with this immutable borrow
now
there are lots of problems with pointers
that references and rust don't have
for example in this code if this was
so what this code is doing is
we are
creating a new variable named y
and we are
assigning it to the result of this new
scope in
the inner curly brackets
in there we are creating variable x that
allocates some heat memory
and then we're trying to return a borrow
to that memory
from that inner scope to the outer scope
the problem with this is that at the end
of the inner scope
x gets cleaned up
and y would have a reference to data
that's that hasn't that doesn't exist
anymore
if we try to compile this code with rust
we get an error that says x does not
live long enough
that we are trying to borrow store a
borrow in y
that
it gets cleaned up the value that it's
borrowing gets cleaned up before we try
and use this
so rust won't even let us compile this
code
which brings me to
good thing number four about russ
which is the error messages
when you feel so mad that you wanna roar
take a deep breath
and read the compiler messages one
two
three
four
you may have looked at that error
message
and you may have looked at error
messages in the past when you're trying
to get your code working
and just gotten really mad that your
code was not doing what you wanted it to
do
and i know i've done this
you
are frustrated and you just want to get
it to work and you switch back from your
terminal to your editor and you start
trying to change things and getting it
to work
and you might be guessing what's wrong
you might have looked at the error
messages and they're not helping so
you're just going to ignore them
but in rust
a lot of work has been put into the
error messages to actually make them
useful and helpful
and
that
means in russ when you get an error
message even though you might get a lot
and that might be really long
they should be helpful in explaining
what you need to do to change your code
and if they're not helpful or they're
not clear we consider that a bug
so i wanted to go through a few examples
of
amazing compiler error messages
in rust there is a construct called
match
which is sort of like a switch or a case
statement but it has some pattern
matching that you might know from
languages like elixir
or erlang
and in this particular match statement
we are
checking the results of
two functions that return booleans
is logged in and is admin and you can
imagine an application
where
you might be logged in as a regular user
you might be logged in as an
administrator user and we want the
application to do different things based
on those two pieces of information
if you are logged in but you're not an
admin we will display a dashboard
if you're logged in and you are in admin
we'll show you the admin settings and if
you're not logged in and you're not an
admin then we'll display the login page
now the problem with this match
statement is that we're missing a case
here we are missing the
false true case so if we try to compile
this match as is
we get an error that says we have
non-exhaustive patterns because in this
case russ can tell that we missed a case
and it even tells us which one we missed
we missed false true
and it points
to our exact code
and shows where the expression is that
we're not
uh
matching all the possible patterns and
it says you can possibly fix this by
adding wild cards or more match arms
and it even tells us what the type of
the value is that we're matching on
so
knowing this we can go back to our code
and take a look and say okay what should
we do
for the
false true case
and in this case
it really doesn't make any sense to be
not logged in but be an admin so what we
want to do is the same thing as false
false and we can do that by creating a
catch-all kind of case
and handle both the remaining cases
by matching anything remaining and
displaying the login
in this next example
i have a variable with a number in it
and then i have an if statement where
i have forgotten to
do double equals i
i just have a single equals in the if
count equals 20.
and in some languages like ruby
uh that i'm not saying i've done this
before but i might have done this before
uh this would actually assign
to
the count variable and happily continue
on and do something that is not at all
what you're expecting and there's no
real
uh
indication
that
you're missing an equal sign in where
you mean to be comparing
so
this is this problem if you try to
compile this in rust
it says mismatch types
it says expected bull because
rust is strongly typed and all
expressions in ifs have to evaluate to
booleans
it found uh
empty
parentheses which is the unit type which
is kind of
um there isn't really a return value
because um
assignment statements don't
return anything in rest
and it has some help text saying
maybe you wanted to compare for equality
with double equals here just just to
guess
so then we can go back to our code put
in that extra equal sign and be on our
way
uh
so i really love rust error messages
and
i
it makes me sad when people don't read
them because they are actually really
helpful
and i really appreciate all the work
that has been put into
making them that way and i think that's
pretty special
the next special thing i'd like to talk
about is special thing number five the
rust community
rust friends help each other yes they do
it's
true uh there are lots of things i love
about the people who work on rust and
the people who use rust
one thing i really appreciate is that
there's been a documentation culture
from the beginning
there's been a lot of emphasis on
producing good documentation
uh lots of the libraries that people
have released
the ones that are most popular have
great documentation and people notice
that and want to create other crates
that have great documentation there's
lots of tutorials there's lots of books
and we really
because rust is made up of people who
uh
have felt left out of
other systems problem languages because
they're so hard to learn i feel like we
really
value going the extra mile to help other
people
come into the rest community
another important part of the community
is that russ has had a code of conduct
since it's it was first open sourced
and
we also have it's not just words we have
a
wonderful amazing moderation team all
volunteers who do a lot of work to
uh ensure that our code of conduct is
upheld
we're not perfect by any means
there have been problems there will be
more problems but
we
are made up of people who
value
a professional community where everyone
is treated respectfully
and
that's really important to me
the other thing that's really important
about the community and how the
community works on rust
is that major decisions
and major changes are made through this
open decision-making process called the
rfc process request for comments
and it can be really tiring because it's
kind of talking with everyone and
building consensus and that takes time
and it's difficult sometimes
but
uh even when
the consensus is not what you'd want it
to be at least you are able to see what
the rationale is for that and
see what the trade-offs were because
we've talked about them all in the open
and appreciate why we might why
what the language or
crates or um
other parts of
rust might have made that decision
it's
different from other languages that are
kind of uh developed internally and then
open sourced after the fact where you're
like
why why
why is this this way and there's no way
to figure it out
uh with russ there's often a whole
history of
how that decision was made
and the factors that went into that that
you can look at and explains why things
are the way they are and where they
could be approved and there's a
mechanism for you
to participate in that process and
make changes
and that's i find that to be really
special and really important
okay
to be a little bit balanced here because
clearly i love russ
um i'm gonna talk about one bad thing
about rust
which is that prototyping
a program can be harder in russ than
you're used to in other languages like
maybe ruby or python where you can just
kind of
uh
write out a shell script or sort of
write out a script of some sort to do a
task very quickly
what this might look like is you get to
work and you say okay i see what we have
to do here we just have to take this
data
we're going to move it over to the
system over here and transform it a
little bit
then we're going to move it over here
and display it
and i know how to do all that and i'll
be done by the end of the day
what russ sees when it looks at this
this code that you want to write
is that it says what if this data is
malformed what do you want me to do then
and what if a bear comes in over here
and eats your data it might happen what
do you want me to do about that and what
if your display just isn't there
we have to handle that somehow
and oh you think you're going to be done
by the end of the day no i don't think
so i need to know how we're going to
handle all these problems and you might
not be ready to handle all this problem
you might not know what to do with all
these problems you just want to get the
happy path working and russ can get in
the way sometimes with that there are
ways around it
there's uh there are ways to explicitly
stop your program if it encounters a
certain kinds of errors instead of
handling it
which
safely just kind of
stops your program
and exits and doesn't let you continue
in a bad state
which
in production code you don't want to be
crashing most of the time
so you do want to go back and handle it
handle those places but because you have
to be explicit in rest uh you do have
those places you can search for the
places where you've explicitly ignored
or delegated the error handling
for those cases
and
uh when something seems bad turn it
around
find something good
the way i like to think about this when
i'm running into it
is that
sometimes it's good to code slow
how many times
have you
[Music]
heard this at work no this is just a
prototype we don't have to handle the
errors we don't have to think about that
we're gonna throw it away we're just
trying this
and then you get it working
and
then people start saying
oh this is wonderful it does exactly
what we want we're gonna put it in
production
and suddenly your throwaway code
isn't
so throwaway anymore and that can make a
big maintenance burden to
redo that code while it's running
instead of throwing it away
um
so sometimes i think it's good that rust
slows you down and makes you acknowledge
at least the error cases
that might happen so that when you get
in this situation
where you ending up supporting code
that you didn't think you were going to
support
at least you have those places in the
code to go back to to
handle the errors that you explicitly
ignored
okay
it's almost time to stop so choose one
more thing to talk about
i i couldn't quite fit this last thing
into the daniel tiger theme
so i'm just kind of sneaking in here at
the end
and
another really big thing special about
rust is its tooling and specifically i
want to talk for a little bit about
cargo
cargo is the build tool for rust code it
is a test runner it's the dependency
manager
and all of those functions work together
ensuring that
a lot
the majority of the rest programs that
you can find on github you can pull them
down and just run cargo build and cargo
tests and
it will work it will be able to fetch
all the dependencies and build all those
and you can be off and running
uh c and staples plus don't really have
dependency management and
cargo has learned a lot from uh ruby
gems and bundler and npm and yarn
and
has brought those modern tooling
to the systems programming world and
this is a huge thing that
makes me love rust
that was fun and now this talk's done
thank you neighbor for having fun with
this talk with me i hope you enjoyed the
daniel tiger songs and learning about
rust
have a great day